for more than a century the nodding
donkeys of america's west
have told the story of this country's
thirst for oil
there are many who believe these
landmarks of the fossil fuel boom
should be consigned to history
among them joe biden wielding his
executive order pen again
to undo more of his predecessor's legacy
and putting climate change at the heart
of his presidency in my view we've
already waited too long to deal with
this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer and we see it
with our own eyes we feel it
we know it in our bones and it's time to
act
this is where one of those orders will
be felt the most half of new mexico's
billion dollar oil revenue comes from
drilling on public land
something that will now be restricted
everything in our community revolves
around oil and gas if you own a
restaurant if you own a grocery store
as well as the economic hit drillers
like ray miller say renewables
can't yet fill the void created by
shutting off oil
whether we produce it or not is just
whether we'll be buying it from foreign
sources
that have geopolitical risk or whether
we produce it here in america
and we have great opportunities we're
blessed with the natural resources
good lord put it in the ground for us
but you know whether we
extract it out will be our own uh
determination by the political beings
for the last four years americans saw
their president roll back rules on
things like car emissions
his successor says jobs and national
security will come
from following the science and changing
the culture
i think we're in the middle of a major
shift
i feel more optimistic than i have in a
very long time
president biden has acknowledged that
the fossil fuel
era needs to end and has taken important
steps
already to bring us into the clean
energy future
the things that we need to do to address
the climate emergency or things that are
going to make the world
safer healthier and more equitable for
all of us i thank you all for your time
two-thirds of americans agree
climate change is a global emergency but
biden will face
legal and political challenges will take
more than executive orders
to change the environmental landscape
greg milam sky
news los angeles